[Music]
[Music]
so
can you hear him
they're both up
that's my call that's that's the new
alarm let's start the day
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by jim plus
coffee and i'm gonna be doing a very
much requested what i eat in a day while
i'm vacationing down in sunny florida
with my family but first let me hop in
here and tell you what my sponsor gym
plus coffee so gym plus coffee is an
irish athleisure and lifestyle brand
focused on building community and a
mission to make life richer
i basically live in athleisure where and
i love the quality of this line super
comfy really nice styles and lots and
lots of colors for switching it up so i
basically wear these everywhere now um
you know walking the dog and the kids
hanging around the house running errands
working from home
honestly i don't really see a reason to
get changed
but the chill zip hoodie i'm wearing
right now
so warm and so so comfortable and their
swift high-rise leggings are really
thick and super durable so they're
definitely really high quality and i
love their commitment to sustainability
so right now they are on track to have
30 of their line be fully sustainable
with a hundred percent fully compostable
packaging so you can check out their
shops online in the us new zealand
australia the uk and europe so if you
want to check out gym plus coffee today
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code abby sharp to get 20
off of your order and definitely get
this chill zip hoodie so comfy and so
cute all right back to the video now
before we get into it a huge disclaimer
that what you're about to see is just a
random day of eating it is not a
prescription of how you should eat or
you should eat or you should eat or you
should eat or you should eat in fact no
one should be eating exactly like me so
as always listen to your body and don't
let any influencer including a
professional like me
dictate what you should be eating in a
day but if you're new here do not forget
to subscribe to this channel
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode and also follow
me over on tick tock and instagram for
lots more great content all right let's
get into the day so first things first
we got to get ready for the day so wash
my face brush my teeth you know the
drill
[Music]
so in addition to lots of water
throughout the day the first thing i
have is my sun fiber powder
and that's really just part of my posibo
treatment regimen and it's really
amazing for regularity so the benefit of
being up at the crack of dawn means that
i get
to
have my pick of all the equipment in the
gym because it's just
me all right despite being the only one
in the gym they kicked me out because
apparently
it doesn't open until 7 30.
so he's going to work out outside and we
can do that because it's florida and my
goal right now is to squeeze in a quick
little workout in the condo gym before
the day really gets way too busy to take
any time for myself
this is a glamorous look
um okay now i'm going to do a little
cardio aka
i'm going to answer emails um while i'm
walking on an incline on the treadmill
because this is how apparently
entrepreneurs do
vacation
[Music]
so just finished my workout
i'm taking the stairs up
to the condo because
it's safer means i don't take the
elevator with somebody else
and it's a nice little finisher i love
doing the stairs so it's just a few
flights so
yeah ready for a coffee though
oh in this light
not very flattering
so yesterday was
a
travel day
and if you've ever traveled with kids
you know that it is stressful as f
so
it also was my birthday but i didn't
want it to be my birthday on a super
stressful day it just had to work out
that way so we are redoing my birthday
today we're gonna pretend like yesterday
was not my birthday and today is my
birthday and if it still goes poorly i'm
just gonna keep pushing it out and
milking this until maybe it'll be my
birthday like january 2023
and i won't have aged at all so it
sounds like a pretty good gig for me i'm
just gonna put a little bit of sunscreen
on and like the bare minimum of makeup
so i don't look too scary out there and
i think we're probably gonna take the
kids to the beach um and do some other
really fun things
so but first i'm gonna need a little
coffee and
something to eat
so for breakfast the night before i mix
one of these overnight oats packets with
some oat milk and a little bit of hemp
hearts and then i let it sit in the
fridge overnight
i also made a smoothie yesterday for my
kids so i'm having some leftovers of
that
plus of course i need my morning latte
okay so i have literally two minutes of
silence to wolf this down before the
kids come in um
but it looks really good
overnight protein oats peanut butter
bran flakes because i like a crunch
bananas blueberries i think you put some
hemp parts in here as well last night
two kiwis i usually have two kiwis
pretty much every day now these ones are
skinless
so
you don't even have to peel them but we
know kiwi is really good for digestion
good for bloating so work that at the
routine this is a smoothie i made this
smoothie last night um i make it like a
different variation but i basically just
used what i had on hand so this has
frozen blueberries frozen bananas frozen
spinach um greek yogurt oat milk tons of
hemp hearts like a quarter cup tons of
peanut butter like a quarter cup um and
i just blend that all together and i
think that's all i put in this time yeah
um anyways the kids love it i love it
and it's safe for the kids because it
has um no protein powder in it so really
good
and then the most important thing the
coffee which i put into the most strange
um you know protein powder shaker but i
don't have all my tools here so just
working with what i got and uh yeah
most important meal of the day coffee
and just to show you guys because i know
you're gonna freak out
you don't have to peel them they're
delicious so sweet
kind of tangy oh and super quickly um
also with meals i have a little
supplement arsenal here i take my
iberogast which is helpful for my sibo
um and then in here
um oh gosh i arranged them before i went
so that i didn't have to bring all the
bottles so i'm not 100 sure but i see
peppermint capsule there's ginger in
here maybe this is one of my probiotics
i don't remember so don't quote me on
any of it i just know this is what i
take home
you know when your coffee is not quite
warm but it's also not iced coffee yet
that's the life i'm living right now and
i don't know how i feel about it so let
me get me some ice
this is not the cute beach look
of my 20s
just the schlepping look
of motherhood
oh my god it's windy it's a windy day
okay so you know i am not very good at
turning off but i'm down south for a
reason so we're gonna spend a few hours
collecting seashells and chasing waves
the sun makes me so thirsty so in
addition to like the copious amounts of
water i'm gonna drink today
just gonna have a little of this
mediocre watermelon
before we got lunch
my teeth are so sensitive they can't
even handle watermelon but
i persevere because it's worth it so
update
where we're at in the day
um just got up from the beach inhaled a
container of watermelon i made the kids
some lunch
and they are
going to
go for a nap one of them's gonna nap the
other one's gonna watch some tv and i
think we're gonna go shopping and oh my
gosh like why did i even bother getting
a blowout this is why i always ask
myself when i'm in florida why
get a blowout when this is what happens
to my hair
like within a day it is such a travesty
it is so disappointing and then i have
to put it up and it looks greasy even
though i just had a professionally blown
out and washed a day ago
anyways
um
yeah we're gonna go grab a little bite
probably when we get out there so
let's go
[Music]
i got some take out because there's no
way i'm
eating inside a florida restaurant right
now with omicron going on
but i can't eat cause i'm hungry
so i'm marching back there right now
because
i had ordered
tomato soup to go with my fish tacos
which i know is a very strange
combination but i love their tomato soup
which is why i specifically ordered it
and i was given some other kind of curry
soup which is just not
going to suffice
so i'm going to have to be that
karen
uh asking for
asking for my damn soup
so
gotta get the goods so lunch was amazing
so this little seaside diner place has
the best tomato soup and today i was
also feeling like seafood so i went for
some fish tacos
so that was a really nice adult only
outing i really enjoyed that
i don't get a lot of those
um and lunch was delicious i ate all my
tacos and i would say like three
quarters of the tomato soup i totally
want to eat the rest of them but i was
sweating like this was a poor
poor shirt choice for
for florida um so i was sweating
eating a whole thing of hot soup and
also i wanted to bring a home to
share with my kids because i know they
love tomato soup i should have gotten
them a whole other tomato soup because
they're gonna eat that up tonight
so yeah i think we're going to
um
go get ready and go to the pool and then
hopefully go out for dinner if it's not
raining because we're going to sit on
the patio
and uh yeah
make it a good day make it a good
do-over birthday because that's how we
roll so full disclosure i am not a water
sign
uh i strongly dislike the water
but
i will show up
if there is a cute
like bathing suit print involved
and if it's food related
you know it's for me okay i have a few
minutes to chat here before i'm back on
mom duty because the kids are doing a
puzzle so nicely
um and i want to just like tell you a
little bit about my kind of current
eating routine because it has changed a
lot since um you know i really dove into
this whole sibo journey and i have been
trying to um kind of eat
three larger meals a day and then one
snack a bedtime snack
in the past i was always a grazer um it
was just the way i always ate growing up
um but also i would say that
um
motherhood definitely kind of
exaggerated that because you're always
just you never really know when you're
gonna get a time for a meal right
especially when i was breastfeeding and
like early postpartum you're always just
like putting little bits of your kids
meals and like leftovers and like that
little piece of crust or whatever
whatever's left on their plate is
generally going into my mouth that's
what she said
so i have really tried to be more
mindful about that kind of stuff because
i do want to give my gut a chance to
have a good what we call the migratory
motor complex so the migratory motor
complex is really like a big sweeping
broom that that that moves all the food
particles and everything through the
digestive tract it's very important to
support the migratory motor complex for
sibo reoccurrence and prevention
and in a normal healthy gut that process
happens about every two hours but every
time you put a little bite of food into
your mouth it halts that process so you
really do want to give your body the
time to do that full sweep and in folks
that have sibo it's hypothesized that
you actually need a lot longer between
meals so it could be four to five hours
so i am trying to um have bigger meals
and fewer snacks but i'm in no way
militant about it so today you know i
was out and about with the kids and i
felt like i was hungry slash thirsty and
i saw the watermelon and i had already
had breakfast but i was feeling it like
i really just wanted that watermelon so
i ate the watermelon no harm no foul
it's not gonna it's not the end of the
world my sibo's not gonna come back
because the damn watermelon
stuff like that like we're gonna be okay
and that's kind of just how i'm choosing
to move forward in this journey because
i have to just keep it real it has to be
real life and this honestly is working
really really well and intuitively for
me we just escaped this torrential
downpour it was crazy
um
so it was a quick swim
quick little one
uh but we still got wet
yes we did
and now the kiddos are in the shower
getting warmed up and we're gonna work
on a quick dinner for the kids and then
we're gonna get to go to just us adults
okay so hubby is feeding the kids
i have a few minutes to get ready not
sure if there's any point in me like
straighten my hair because i know it's
so humid outside and we're gonna be
seated on a patio and it's just gonna
look like crap
like by the time i even step out of the
car
so
not sure if it's worth me wasting my
time um but i will throw a little makeup
on top of the makeup
i already got on this is why i'm not a
beauty blogger vlogger or whatever
because i got no skill i got no game i
do it all wrong and i'm just trying to
get it done as fast as i can and get out
the door if that's anyone else's tactic
let me know in the comments below i feel
you but anyways i am very much looking
forward to a
quiet
adult only dinner we don't get a whole
lot of these um not at home and
definitely not when we're on holiday
so yeah i'm
very excited for my pseudo birthday
dinner
and i hope it's a good one oh and
because i'm definitely not going to want
to vlog after after we get home because
it's going to be late i'm going to try
to get into my like sleepy sleepy zone
and that means not working and not
vlogging and not looking at a camera and
not looking at a phone or whatever um
i do take supplements before bed
don't even know what's coming ahead
omega-3
uh magnesium vitamin d
another probiotic i cover some of these
in my sibo video um and then
anything else
than just my medication of course so
um i take davey go for sleeping and i
take um a resotran prokinetic for my
sibo as well ma digestion
and i think
that's it so i'm going to get ready and
i'm excited to eat so dinner out for a
little kind of birthday celebration was
just so so nice it was just so lovely to
get out even if this was going to be the
last patio outing we would have before
omicron just totally exploded and we
basically became hermes again
but i was pretty full by the time our
mains came so i basically ate half of
the burger and like a couple fries and a
bite each of the brussels sprouts and
the slaw but of course somehow i had
room for dessert and i ate like half of
the bread pudding but i packed the rest
of all the little bits of our meal up
and i ate it for brunch the next day
double birthday win and on that note
folks that is all that i have for you
guys today a big thank you to gym plus
coffee for sponsoring if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what you'd like to see
me do next subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you